جندي طيار رجل اعمال ملاكم ومخترع لكن
اختارها عمله خبيرا للتجسس وممثلا كبيرا
للمخابرات البريطانيه لنصف الكره الغربي
باكمله خلال الحرب العالميه فكان شخصا
بعده وجوه تعود كلها لرجل واحد
في عام
1897 في كندا ولان والديه لم يكون قادرين
على تربيته فتبنته عائله ايسلنديه ومنحته
كنيه ستيفنسون ترك المدرسه في سن مبكره
وعندما اندلعت الحرب العالميه الاولى تطوع
للخدمه في قوه المشاهدين ثم انتقل مع
الجيش الى انجلترا حيث اصبح طيارا وملاك
في سلاح الطيران الملكي وسجلتنا 10
انتصارا قبل ان يتم اسقاط طائره في احدى
المهمات كما قبض عليه الالمان واحتجزوه
لكنه نجح في الهروب في اكتوبر عام
1918 بعد الحرب العالميه الاولى حصل
ستيفنسون على رتبه نقيب وعلى الصليب
العسكري وصليب الطيران المتميز ثم انتقل
الى بريطانيا حيث اصبح صناعيا ومخترعا
ناجحا وحصل مع زميله جورج دبليو على براءه
اختراع لنظام لنقل الصور الفوتوغرافيه عبر
اللاسلكي بالاضافه الى حقوق براءه اختراع
عديده فجنا ثروه جيده سمحت له بالانخراط
في مجالات مختلفه كصناعه الصلب وصناعه
السيارات وعالم الطيران كما كان من الرعيل
الاول من الذين عملوا في هيئه الاذاعه
البريطانيه بي بي سي
بنا ستيفنسون قاعده واسعه من الاتصالات
الصناعيه بالعالم اضافه لسطوته في صناعه
السينما حيث امتلك استديوهات شبرتن التي
كانت الاكبر في العالم خارجه هوليود في
وقت مبكر من ابريل عام
1936 كان ستيفنسون يقدموا طواعيه معلومات
سريه لعضو البرلمان البريطاني ونستون
شرشال حول كيفيه قيام حكومه ادولف هتلر
ببناء قواتها المسلحه واخفاء ان نفقات
العسكريه رغم ان ذلك شكل انتهاكا واضحا
لشروط معاهده فرساي ويرفع حده التهديد
النازي المتزايد للامن الاوروبي والدولي
مع بدء الحرب العالميه الثانيه ارسل شيرل
رئيس الوزراء 7 سوني الى الولايات المتحده
لتاسيس واداره التنسيق الامني البريطاني
فتم تسجيله منظمه بالسي كاكيان اجنبيه وتم
تعريفه انا باسم مكتبي مراقبه الجوازات
البريطانيه فكان مقرا تشغيليا للاتصالات
بين منظمات الامن والاستخبارات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه
اثرت المنظمه الجديده بشكل مباشر على
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه والغربيه تجاه
وجهات النظر المؤيده لبريطانيا والمناهضه
لدول المحور كما كانت مقرا لتدريب
المشغلين السريين من الطرفين اضافه
لمهمتها غير الرسميه بانشاء شبكه
استخبارات بريطانيه سريه
الفضل في تغيير الراي العام الامريكي نحو
دعمي دخول امريكا في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وكان يشتهر باسمه الرمزي
للاستخبارات في زمن الحرب
لمجهوده الحربي
من الملك جورج السادس واسامه الاستحقاق من
الرئيس هاري استرومان ثم اختار ان ينزله
في منزل خاص اشتراه في برموده ومكت فيه
حتى وفاته في عام 1989
شكلت سيره ستيفن سون التي يلفها جانب من
الغموض مصدر الهام للكثير من المؤلفين
الذين جعلوه بطلا لمؤلفاتهم حتى ان ايان
فلمنج صرح ذات مره بان الشخصيه جيمس بوند
تكاد تكون نسخه رومانسيه للغايه من جاسوس
حقيقي ثم اضاف هذا الشخص الحقيقي وليام
ستيفنسون